[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في بانورام في ظل اسمرار
التوتر المتصاعد بين الصين والولايات
المتحده يحذر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الاسبق هيرك سنجر من حرب باردتان اكثر
خطوره من الاولى التي اندلعت بين الولايات
المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي وحلفائهما من
منتصف الاربعينيات حتى اوائل التسعينيات
لاسيما والتوتر يرتفع حول قضيه جزيره
تايوان وملف التجسس سواء عبر البانولات او
تطبيق تيك توك فضلا عن التوجس الامريكي من
التقارب الصيني الروسي
كيسينجر استند في تحريره الى ان واشنطن
تمتلكان موارد اقتصاديه متشابهه وهو ما لم
يكن متوفرا خلال الحرب البارده الاولى
وربما في مقابله مع الصحيفه الاسبانيه الى
ان القوتين الاقتصاديتين الضخمتين تحولتا
في الوقت الراهن الى
خصمينجر حضر سابقا من خطوره حدوث صراع
صينيين امريكي هذا التنبيه وافقته مخاوف
من ان يتحول مثل هكذا صراع الى اكبر تحد
يواجه البشري
الحرب البارده
ظهر المصطلح نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
مع الخلاف بين امريكا والسوفيات بشان
كيفيه اداره ما بعد الحرب واعاده بنائه
استمرت حاله الحرب البارده من منتصف
الاربعينيات حتى اوائل التسعينيات
ابتسمت تلك الفتره بالتوتر في العلاقات
بين الامريكان والسوفيات قام البلدان
بتنميه ترسانته ماء العسكريه كما دخل في
صراعات سياسيه
انضموا الينا في الحديث في هذا الموضوع في
الاستوديو الهام لي الصحفي الصيني
عبر سكايب الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في
الشونه السياسيه
الامريكيه ابدا من واشنطن سيد عباس نحن
بالفعل امام حرب بارده ثاني هذه المره بين
الولايات المتحده والصين كما يحذر كسنجر
شكرا لك على هذه الاستضافه وتحيه لك
الكريم في الاستوديو وجمهورك هناك يبدو
الان فعلا بوادر حرب بارده بين الصين
والولايات المتحده
غزو اوكرانيا
والتصاعد
المشاكل بخصوص تايوان قضيه التجسس الملكيه
الفكريه
يعني دخول الصين في مناطق جديده في العالم
اقتصاديا واحساس وجود احساس امريكي انه
لابد للولايات المتحده ان ترد ايضا
اقتصاديا المنافسه العسكريه كل هذه هي
المواد الاوليه التي صنعت فكره الحرب
البارده في نهايه الاربعينيات لكني طبعا
لا اعتقد ان هذه الحرب البر هي لم تتشكل
لكن البوادر واضحه قد تنتهي هذه البوادر
او تتراجع بعد نها حرب اوكرانيا او وصلوا
الطرفين الى تفاهم لكن ان ناضجت هذه
البوادر وتشكلت فعلا فكره الحرب البارده
الجديده فهي لن تكون اخطر من الحرب
البارده القديمه الحرب البارده القديمه من
الاتحاد السوفيتي الولايات المتحده كانت
طرفان ينشران صواريخ نوويه وكانت هناك
استراتيجيه
التدمير المتبادل من يدمر الطرف الاخر نحن
هنا باساء تنافس
اقتصادي وتنافس على النفوذ وعلى الترافس
معروف خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالاقتصاد بجزيره تايوان ولكن سؤالي للسيد
الهام ليه هل بكين معنيه بهذه التحذيرات
وهذه تحضيرات تصدر من شخصيه سياسيه
امريكيه ثقيله الوزن مثل
طبعا هذا تحذير تحذير شديد وخصوصا بالنسبه
لكن في الحقيقه الصين كانت هناك
تصريح واضحه جدا تجاه الولايات المتحده
واتجاه السياسيين الامريكان بان الصين لا
تسعى للمنافسه الحقيقيه او المنافسه
العسكريه مع الولايات المتحده وبطبيعه
الحال يعني لا اريد او لا احب استخدم
مصطلح الحرب البارده الثانيه لان يعني
هناك عده فرق
اختلاف بين الحرب الماضيه وهذه المنافسه
بين الولايات المتحده والصين اذا حدثت هذه
الحربه سيكون ينحرب اشد بكثيره بعده اضعاف
من مقارنه مع حرب الاولى وثاني شيء
بالنسبه
للحرب البارده الاولى فكانت بدايه هذه
الحرب
بمبداه رومان في عام
حتى وزير الخارجيه الصيني
حذر من ان اي حرب بارده ثانيه بينه
المتحده والصين ستؤدي الى كارثه بشريه اذا
الصين تتعامل بجديه مع هذه التحضيره نعم
طبعا هذا يعني للدفاع عن المصلحه الجوهريه
بالنسبه للصين وايضا للدفاع على حفاظ على
الاستقرار العالم وسلامه وبالاضافه الى
ذلك يعني اذا نتكلم عن حرب البارده هناك
رمز مهم جدا لحرب البارده الاولى وهي
تشكيل منظمه معاهده بقياده الاتحاد
الرسوفياتي ولكن حتى الان بالنسبه
لجمهوريه الصين شعبيه ما لديه التسريحه
واضحه لتشكيل تحالف عسكري مقابل حلفونات
او رقمه على هناك رغبه من الولايات
المتحده لتشكيل نسخه اسيويه لحلف الناتو
وهذا اشاره خطيره جدا من جانب الامريكي
الى جانب الصين ولكن حتى الان اعتقد وحسب
قراءه الاجابه
واقعيه وعقلانيه طيب ولكن اذا في هذه
الحاله سيد عقيل عباس لماذا تستفز واشنطن
بكين تحاول انجاح حلف شبيه للنيتو في اسيا
تقترب اكثر من الحدود الصينيه من خلال
تايوان تزيد ميزانيه الدفاعيه كما حضر
قاده البنتاجون من ان هناك لابد من
الاستعداد الى حرب مع الصين هل المساله هي
تمرير ميزانيه الضغط عليها من اجل عدم
التدخل في الحرب في اوكرانيا ام ان هناك
بالفعل نيه امريكيه لايجاد مواجهه ماء
سواء كانت اقتصاديه عسكريه سياسيه سمها ما
شئت مع بكين
يعني اولا الخطاب بخصوص كون الصين منافسا
واحيانا
طرفا خطرا هناك فرق بين التنافس وبين طرف
خطر عسكريا هذا الخطاب في واشنطن وربما في
تصاعد منذ 2014
منذ رئاسه الرئيس اوباما في حينها والاطار
كان اقتصاديا بدل التركيز عن الشرق الاوسط
مركز على اسيا الى اخره لكنه ايضا تاطير
هذه القضيه باطارها الصحيح مهم بخصوص
الدخول العسكري الامريكي في اسيا يعني قرب
الصين لا اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده
اعلنت او هي مهتمه بحرب بارده او تريد
حلفا عسكريا هناك واقع الحال وهذا يختفي
في الخطاب السياسي الصيني والخطاب
الاعلامي الصيني الدولي المحيطه يعني حول
البحر الصيني الجنوبي تشتكي تقلق من
السلوك من التوسع من الصيد المبالغ به
للاسماك من صناعه جزر من اعاده تعريف
الحدود المياه الاقليميه يعني هذه شكاوى
تاتي من اليابان تاتي من الفلبين تاتي من
حلفاء الولايات المتحده في المنطقه طبعا
بينهم وهؤلاء كوريا الجنوبيه يصرون
يطالبون باستمرار الولايات المتحده ان
تؤكد حضورها العسكري لانهم يشعرون انهم
غير قادرين على مواجهه الصين طموحه
ومتمكنه على نحو متزايد فهذا هو
لا يمكن ترك المجال فقط للصين هناك حلفاء
لواشنطن يطالبون بوجودها في المنطقه بشكل
مباشر
وبالتالي لابد من وجود من يقف طموحات
الصين في اسيا وفي المناطق التي يوجد فيها
حلفاء لوشن نعم اول شيء يعني هذه الحلفاء
موجوده منذ زمن
ولكن في الفتره الحاليه او فتره الاخيره
يعني شهدت هذا التحالف
توسعا وخصوصا عندما شاهدنا التشكيل لتحالف
او
لمنظمه اوكوس وايضا للتعاون بشان
السفن الحربيه النوويه بين الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا وهذه اشاره
ايضا خطيره جدا تجاه الصين فيعني هناك
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا لضيفي من واشنطن
عقيل عباس
[موسيقى]